MALE SPEAKER: And welcome to
Authors at Google, Cambridge
Edition.
We're very happy today
to have two guests
from central Massachusetts.
Or is it western?
DEAN STIGLITZ: Central.
MALE SPEAKER: Central
Massachusetts with us.
Laurie Herboldsheimer
and Dean Stiglitz.
Laurie and Dean
live in Leominster.
Quick quiz.
Birthplace of Johnny Appleseed.
DEAN STIGLITZ: And the
pink plastic lawn flamingo.
LAURIE HERBOLDSHEIMER: Ooh.
And Tupperware.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: And
Golden Rule honey.
DEAN STIGLITZ: Yes.
Especially.
MALE SPEAKER: They
breed and keep bees.
They market
treatment-free honey.
They run beekeeping
conferences and classes.
They write and do research.
They're active in the Worcester
Beekeepers Association.
They travel around
the country speaking
about treatment-free
beekeeping and the importance
of microbial
environment in beehive.
Golden Rule Honey LLC
is their honey business.
And they maintain a certified
food production facility
located in the building where
the pink plastic flamingo was
born.
So you're getting a piece of
history with every container.
Very important.
DEAN STIGLITZ: The future's
in plastics, right?
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: That
and they package,
distribute, and
retail honey from
other treatment-free
beekeeping operations.
And they produce the
queen of chocolate
as the king of chocolate.
I feel I need to
meet this individual.
But it's actually a unique
cocoa-free mix, dairy products
and sweetened only with honey.
And if you want to get in
touch with them after this,
you can go to their site which
is beeuntothers.com or email
them at info@ beeuntoothers.com.
So please join me in
welcoming Dean and Laurie.
[APPLAUSE]
DEAN STIGLITZ: Well, I'm really
glad to be here at Google,
and I'm hoping that
one of you is working
on charging my phone over
4G because the battery keeps
dying.
We're really happy to be here
and talk about some things
about beekeeping.
This is going to be a little
bit of a mishmash of a talk.
I'm going to cover a
lot of different bases,
things that are on our mind
that we think are important
and we think that are important
that other people understand
as well.
So first, a little bit
of baseline beekeeping.
So a few facts and numbers
to put the beekeeping
industry in this
country in perspective.
It's a little bit like
the Occupy Movement
except the opposite, that
99% of the bees in the US
are owned by 1%
of the beekeepers.
It's not terribly surprising.
Some of these beekeepers
have 70,000 colonies.
But we're talking
about somewhere
in the order of
1,000 beekeepers that
are keeping 99% of the
bees in this country.
Three quarters of the bees
in this country-- which
is, of course, mostly
from these 1,000
beekeepers-- they
all go to California
to pollinate the almonds.
The beehives are
loaded on trucks
from all over the
country and trucked
into the same part of California
for the same two, three weeks
every spring in order to
pollinate the almonds.
And then all those bees,
they leave that area
and they go everywhere
else in the country.
And if you were
going to design a way
to refine new
diseases and pathogens
and spread them as quickly
around the country as
possible--
Did anybody else,
when they were a kid,
get sent to a
chickenpox party so
that you could catch chickenpox?
That's what this
almond thing is.
It really is an incredible
thing that happens.
Another thing that's kind of
interesting that's easy for us
to lose sight of is that
the value of hive products
have shifted over time.
And what I mean by that is
that honey hasn't always
been the thing of value.
And honey today isn't
the thing of value.
The thing of value
today is pollination.
That's how we feed our country
with our monocrop system
that we employ to
feed the masses.
And I'm not going to talk
too much about that today.
But understand that
in colonial England
the wax was what was important.
How come?
Because they didn't
have electric lights.
And beeswax candles put out
a very bright white light
and they don't produce soot.
Whereas other oils
and stuff produced
soot and dirtied the air
and dirtied the walls.
So beeswax was the
important thing.
And we went from a time when
wax was the important product
and now we've got all kinds
of substitutes for the beeswax
like electric lights.
And then honey became
the important thing.
But really, what's important
right now is the pollination.
Actually, we've got one customer
that eats a lot of honey,
but aside from
him, nobody's going
to go hungry if they
don't get honey.
The other thing that's important
is that treating and feeding
the bees is near
universal, and I'm
going to talk a
little bit about that.
So when I say treatments--
talk about the reasons
that treatments are used--
when I talk about treatments
I'm talking about
medications, substances
that are put in the hive
specifically to fight disease
or to fight something
or to boost something.
This particular bee here, if
you can see closely right where
I'm circling, that bee actually
has a varroa mite on its back.
That's an exotic Asian mite
that came to this country
sometime around 1985.
And it really is probably the
biggest problem that we've got.
It looks like a little limpet
or something sitting on the bee.
It's a mite, so
it has eight legs.
It's a little oval shaped.
If you look closely--
not on that picture,
but on other pictures--
you can see the little legs
on the sides.
Aside from mites-- and
that's a varroa mite,
which is one type of mite
that we have-- we also
have a tracheal mite, which is
a microscopic internal mite.
There are also some
bacterial infections
that we have to deal with.
There's nosema, and I put
that it's own category
because nosema is one of
our oldest known microbial
pathogens.
Nosema is what Pasteur was
looking at with the silk worm
larvae when he kind of figured
out that the infection was
coming from, actually,
this microscopic organism.
There are different kinds of
nosema that we have with bees.
But it's nosema nonetheless.
And nosema is kind
of a funny thing.
It's been classified
as a fungi in the past.
It's now classified as a
microsporidian which, best I
can tell you is that's something
that's almost like a fungi
but isn't quite.
And of course, the
overall reason to treat
is to increase productivity.
Now there are several
types of treatments
that are used in beehives.
And remember, I was
talking about treatments
that are near universal.
That really pretty much
anybody keeping bees,
whether they're going to a hobby
beekeeping class or they're
commercial beekeepers,
using some of this stuff.
The most obvious stuff are
the synthetic chemicals.
And these are
synthetic pesticides.
We have the same
kinds of pesticides.
pesticides that are
used in agriculture
and other areas.
Fluvalinate is the first one.
This is something
that's used for mites.
And it a pyrethroid, which
is a synthetic analog
of a toxin from a
chrysanthemum flower.
There's a lot of different
pyrethroids out there.
Fluvalinate is one of them.
Coumaphos.
Anybody heard the
term organophosphate?
Does everyone know that?
Organophosphates are
a class of pesticides
that were pretty much phased
out of as much of agriculture
as we possibly can.
Would it surprise you
to know that coumaphos
is a organophosphate that's
allowed to be used in beehives
that are going to be producing
honey for human consumption?
Hopefully there's not very
much of it left in the hive
when the honey's
being taken out.
But these are serious
synthetic pesticides,
the kinds of things that
as environmentalists we're
all trying to get out
of the environment.
But of course, beekeepers
are telling farmers
not to use some of this stuff
while they're putting it
in the hives, which makes
it a little bit difficult.
So those synthetic
chemicals, they
are agricultural pesticides.
Then we have some antibiotics
for the bacterial diseases
that we were talking about.
Specifically, TM is an
abbreviation for Terramycin,
tertracycline, kind of the
standard broad spectrum
antibiotics that we're
used to in agriculture
and in human use.
And Tylan is a newer
antibiotic that's
been introduced because, of
course, the bacterial diseases
that Terramycin
is being used for
are becoming resistant to it.
So they have to add
another antibiotic that
lasts a little bit longer.
And there's been
a third one that's
been added there that I
forget the name of it.
And I have never used
any of these in a hive,
so I don't have any direct
first-hand experience
with them.
Fumidil is really interesting.
It's classified as an antibiotic
so I have it under there.
Fumidil is a fungal toxin
like a lot of antibiotics.
It's produced by a fungus.
And it's actually
produced by a fungus that
causes another disease
in the beehive.
There's a whole balancing act of
all these microbes in the hive.
And just like any complex
microbial culture,
they have antagonistic
relationships
towards one another.
So a disease called stonebrood,
and the causative organism
for stonebrood produces
this toxin called Fumidil.
Now Fumidil, we
use against nosema.
Or, I shouldn't say we.
Again, it's something
I've never used.
Fumidil's used against nosema.
It's really the only thing
that works against nosema.
It was originally
developed for human use,
but it was not
approved for human use
because it causes
massive birth defects.
And like a lot of fungal toxins,
I put this in its own category
here because even though it's
technically an antibiotic,
we're using it against
a microsporidian which
is much closer to a
fungi than a bacteria.
But like a lot of
fungal toxins, it
has a lot of other
weird qualities.
The reason it was being
developed for human use
was it actually restricts
blood supply to tumors.
This isn't what we think of when
we think of a broad spectrum
antibiotic that kills bacteria.
This has a lot of different
effects on things.
And I don't ever want to be
in contact with it myself.
Then in addition
to these treatments
there are-- I should
have little finger
quotes on there--
natural treatments.
These are substances that
do occur naturally, never
naturally in the concentrations.
They're used in the
hive as a medication.
In the concentrations
that they're used,
they're just as unnatural
as anything synthetic.
Nature doesn't concentrate
them to that amount.
They're in a
concentration that nature
doesn't have any
way to deal with.
This would never
happen in nature.
It's kind of like
making 180 proof vodka.
Yeah, you might get some fruit
that ferments a little bit.
You have some alcohol in nature.
But that's totally different
than Devils Springs vodka,
and I know that firsthand.
So the organic acids
are natural treatments.
They do occur naturally
in the hive and in honey.
And therefore in
both cases they're
not detectable in
honey as residue
because you'd have to determine
what was in the honey before
and what was added to the honey.
They're substances that do occur
in honey in varying amounts.
And essential oils are
a really important one.
Plants produce essential oils
for a very specific reason.
They do that in order to
prevent microbes and insects
and other small critters
from eating them.
They are toxins.
And essential oils
are used in the hive
by a lot of beekeepers,
a lot of beekeepers
who consider what they're
doing natural and sustainable.
They certainly consider it more
natural and more sustainable
and better for the bees
than the beekeepers that
are using the synthetic
chemicals up there.
But I'm not really
convinced that the impacts
are any less of a problem.
That the essential
oils, do they really
knock out a lot of the microbes?
As we'll talk about in a
little bit, although it's not
the main focus of this talk, the
microbial culture in the hive
and in the bees is
just as important
as the bees are for the bees.
So what happens
when you treat bees?
What are the impacts?
Why am I up here talking
to you about treating
bees and why I don't
think it's right?
Well, first of all, it
interrupts a whole bunch
of these abbreviated CAS,
Complex Adaptive Systems.
A beehive is one giant set
of complex adaptive systems.
The bees, as a colony, they
have this very complex behavior
that we can observe.
But on an individual
level we're looking
at little tiny robots with
very similar programs.
And it's when they get
together, and it's not
like unlike if anybody's ever
read the Isaac Asimov "I,
Robot" stories.
In the first volume
there's one story
about these very simple
robots that actually
work as a little
social organization.
And I think of that every
time I think of the bees.
And that's how
everything happens.
There isn't a queen
that's sitting
on a throne telling
everybody what to do.
When there's more brood
in the hive, more baby
bees in the hive than they
have food to provide for them,
then more bees get allocated
to procuring more food.
It really is as simple as that.
And so when you put these
treatments in the hive-- first
of all, most of them have
not the synthetic pesticides
but the other ones, tend
to have very strong scents.
And of course the bees
communicate with one another
through pheromones.
As a super organism
body, the communication
between individuals
is through smelling.
When you throw something
strong in there
like vaporized organic acid
or an essential oil that
has a very strong smell,
you're interrupting
all that communication
that happens
between individuals
and groups of bees.
All this stuff
affects the microbes.
Especially, of course, the
antibiotics, and of course
the synthetic
pesticides do as well.
And unfortunately so do
the more natural ones,
the essential oils
and the organic acids.
But more importantly, if you
take a step back on a bigger
scale, we've got
this hive of bees
and we're medicating
them every year
or every two months
or every three months
or whatever we're
doing to get rid
of some parasite
or some disease,
we're constantly
interfering with the balance
between the host
and the parasite.
We can never achieve balance
because we're constantly
pushing in one direction,
which is causing the push
to come back from the
opposite direction.
So the direct effects
of treatments.
Brood loss-- almost all the
treatments that I've listed,
almost anything that
you can put in the hive
has the potential certainly to
kill some of the young bees.
That isn't a disaster
all the time,
but it does have an
impact on the hive.
Most of them affect
fertility, and that's
both of queens and of drones.
So both halves of
the mating system.
If you have drones
that are sterile
or drones that have sperm
that's affected that goes
and mates with the
queen that's supposed
to live for three years and
store that sperm for that three
years.
If that sperm dies
in four months
like one study out of
Virginia Tech has shown, then
what good has that mating
done for a year from now?
You've got dead
sperm in the queen.
She can't produce
a viable offspring.
It impacts the queen.
It's very common
that the queen gets
replaced after
treatments are used.
LAURIE HERBOLDSHEIMER: By bees.
DEAN STIGLITZ: By the bees.
The imbalance and the
smells and all that stuff.
The bees think that
something's wrong.
And when something's wrong, you
always go to the CEO, right?
The microbial impacts, again.
A lot of these treatments,
they encourage some microbes
and they put back
some other microbes.
It just throws off the
whole balance of things
and keeps things running.
It perverts the
reproductive selection.
What bees are we selecting from?
If we're treating them, how
do we know which ones we want?
If we want bees that don't
need to be treated how do we--
We can have all the
metrics in the world
about the number of
mites, how quickly
they build up and
all this stuff.
But if what we
want are bees that
can take care of themselves and
survive despite the challenges,
there's really only one
way to measure that metric.
And that is to let bees survive
without the challenges, and to,
as I flippantly say,
not breed from the ones
that died over the winter.
It is that simple.
And the use of many
of these treatments
requires more
treatments, and I'll
talk about that in a couple
of specific cases coming up.
But we sell honey.
And we talk to a lot
of people all the time.
And when we say,
oh, we have honey
from bees that are never
medicated they say, well,
what about the crops that
the bees are foraging on?
You can't keep all the
chemicals out of the hive,
and that's absolutely true.
But there's been very good
work out of Penn State
specifically that looked
at the amount of pesticides
and agricultural
chemicals in the hive.
And what was found was that
by far, the highest levels
were the ones that
the beekeepers are
putting in the hive.
And specifically
fluvalinate and coumaphos.
We're not talking about
the greener stuff.
We're talking about
synthetic pesticides.
organophosphates in hives.
These are the things that are at
the highest level in the hives.
So obviously, any of you
that have worked on teams,
it's the low hanging
fruit that you go for.
Well, I can't really
dictate what a farmer does
or what a neighbor does.
But I can dictate what
I put in the hives.
So beekeepers can actually
control what goes in the hives.
So that's really
a good reason why
we ought to control
what it is because it's
at the highest levels.
We've got a lot of issues
with synergistic effects
in some of these pesticides with
other agricultural chemicals.
That something like
fluvalinate, when
it gets combined with
a fungicide that's
being used in the field, it can
increase the toxicity to bees,
and in some cases has been
reported as much as 1,000
times.
That's a problem.
But it isn't just
the farmers' problem.
The example I like to use is
if you walk to work everyday
and there's a bus that comes
by, and every time that bus goes
by a cloud of exhaust
comes right in your face
and you start coughing.
And you complain, I'm
going to be sick from this
and I'm not well, well, you
might have a case there.
But if you're also smoking
three packs of cigarettes a day,
you're going to have a little
bit more trouble making
that case.
And that's one of
the problems is
once we start talking
about synergistic effects,
we the beekeepers have to take
some responsibility for that.
And there's a lot of controversy
about what pesticides
are doing what to what
bees and what effects they
have on the environment.
But only when all
the contamination
is coming into the hive is
coming in from the outside
and not being put
there by the beekeeper,
are we going to have any
clue what's actually going on
and what things
have what effect.
So now I'll talk a
little bit about feeding.
Because as you'll
see, feeding is also
a universal practice
among beekeepers.
There's a bunch of
reasons for feeding.
Most obviously is to
prevent starvation.
That's not a terrible
reason to feed the bees.
Feeding is also done to
replace harvested stores.
The honey gets taken
off in the fall.
Then the bees are fed.
Generally around here we
don't have a whole lot
of beekeepers that are big
enough operations if they're
buying truckloads of
high fructose corn syrup.
But that's the common practice.
And what you'll see is certainly
white sugar, table sugar,
just being mixed into
a serum and being
fed to the bees for
them to over winter
on so that the
beekeeper can have
the honey on their
breakfast table.
I think the bees want the
honey on their breakfast table.
They don't want
that refined sugar
just as much as
we don't want it.
If there was no
difference we wouldn't
be doing all this work.
We'd just be taking
that refined sugar
and putting it on the breakfast
table and skipping the honey
and letting the bees keep it.
Feeding can be done
to stimulate the bees.
Sometimes, and under the
proper circumstances,
a small amount of
feeding does a great job
of stimulating the bees to go
out and actually collect honey.
Stimulation's a great
reason to feed the bees.
And of course it doesn't
have to be artificial sugar.
It could be honey.
One of the most important
reasons for feeding
is to increase the carrying
capacity of an area.
Because what we get in nature
from the flowers, which
is where the bees
get the nectar, is we
get what beekeepers
call honey flows.
That's a time and an
area where there's
a lot of nectar available.
Well, when there's a
lot of nectar available,
when there's a flow
going on, you almost
can't have too many
hives in an area.
There is more for
the bees to collect
than you could
fit bees in there.
So you're not going
to run out of food.
You've got 100 hives there.
They're all gaining weight.
They're all storing honey.
Well, that's fine.
But we've got the flip side
of that coin, which is dearth.
So you've got that same area.
You've got that
same hundred hives.
And there's rarely
nothing blooming.
But maybe there's only
enough forage in that area
to support five
hives, not a hundred.
Well, what you're going
to see is all the hives
losing population and
losing their stores
because it isn't there.
And so to increase the carrying
capacity of the area, what
I'm talking about is feeding the
bees during a dearth in order
to be able to take
advantage of the flow.
In order to have
the large population
of bees for the flow.
And of course the most
common reason to feed bees
is to produce more bees.
Again, we have talked about
the almond pollination
in California.
That happens in February.
In order to have
large numbers of bees
to do pollination
in February, you
have to start building
them up in November.
And you start building
them up in November
when, if left to
their own devices,
they'd be winding
down to not hibernate,
but to be a little bit
dormant during the winter.
And we're doing the
opposite to them.
So producing more
bees, that's what
you do when you
want to do almonds,
and it's what you do when you
want to have bees to sell.
When you're part of the
package industry in the south
or in California, they
have bees that they
feed a lot that turn
them into more bees
so they can sell bees.
And in fact, those are
the characteristics
that those bees are
bred for, is to be
able to feed them and
have them reproduce.
Because remember, the
product is pollination.
It isn't honey.
And if the product
is pollination,
you want to be
able to get numbers
of bees almost on demand.
So as I said, of course feed
is not equivalent to honey.
It's very common around here.
In the middle of the
summer, we get a dearth.
And it's very common
around here for beekeepers
to just toss feed on them.
Sugar on the hives as
soon as there's a dearth.
So they can keep the numbers up.
And it's not a
ridiculous theory.
But what they're trying to do
is to keep the population up
so when the next
honey flow comes,
they have enough bees
to collect that honey.
Because each bee
in their lifetime
can only collect about a
twelfth of a teaspoon of honey.
So it really is about having
a large number of bees
when that nectar is available.
Feeding effects the
microbial cultures much
like the treatments do.
But most importantly, it
prevents the selection
for bees that don't
require feeding.
We overwinter some
very small colonies.
And when they come
out of winter,
they started out full of honey.
And when they come out of
winter, still with stores.
We know that they didn't
consume very much honey
over the winter, because where
would they have gotten it
if wasn't in that one box?
And what we've found is
that as we're selecting bees
to survive in this area
that they are being selected
for frugality, for not going
through a whole lot of stores
in the wintertime.
Whereas the bees that
you purchase generally
do through a lot of
stores because they're
designed to feed and
turn into young bees.
And of course, feed can
easily get into honey.
We've had honey
tested off the shelf
and found up to 30% bee sugar
in honey that was $11 a pound
and supposedly from an
organic farm in Massachusetts.
And my contention is that
if beekeepers really wanted
to keep the feed
out of the honey,
really wanted to keep
that sugar syrup,
whether it's bee sugar or
corn sugar or cane sugar out
of the honey, they'd flavor
it or they'd color it
so that if it got into
the honey they'd know it
and they wouldn't
sell the honey.
Nobody does that.
And everybody claims that not
much sugar gets into the honey,
but nobody really
tries to verify that.
When it's done conscientiously
it does not get into the honey.
It's very easy not to
do it conscientiously.
And of course, when you're
running a big operation,
every visit to the bee
yard costs you something.
And so you tend to kind of stack
things on top of each other.
And so you put your
feeders on and you
put your honey [? sweepers
?] on at the same time,
and that's actually
fairly common practice.
So another thing I'd
like to talk to you about
is bees being wild animals and
not domesticated livestock.
Bees are wild and I think
they should stay wild.
It's their wildness that
makes them valuable to us.
We often get this
question, how do you
get the bees to come home?
This picture is actually
of some of our hives
on the roof of the restaurant
at the Intercontinental Hotel
right on the waterfront.
And bees come home because
that's where their nest it.
As individuals they
don't really exist.
They exist as part of
this super organism.
Well, what's in the hive?
Well, the queen's in the hive.
All their comb is in the hive.
Their food stores
are in their hive.
Their young are in the hive.
Their future's in the hive.
Everything's in the hive.
So getting the bees to come
home is not hard as long
as you get them established
in their home first.
So some of the things
that make bees wild
is that unlike
livestock, the bees,
they pretty much feed
and care for themselves.
And they're not confined.
They go out and they fly.
They might fly three
miles away from the hive
and come back, or even further.
So this picture,
of course, you can
see a bee forging
on a sunflower.
And I think this is
on the Greenway Park.
And this is actually pollen
that the bees have stored
in the comb and it's
actually being fermented.
And the fermented pollen, when
they ferment it-- just like,
anybody here ever made pickles?
Like, not vinegar pickles
but lacto fermented pickles.
They get sour.
They get preserved.
But more importantly,
the process
of fermentation in that this
is a process of microorganisms,
mostly fungi and bacteria
actually transforming
the substance of the
pollen into substances
that the bees need
outside of the bee's body.
They're actually
synthesizing proteins
and they're synthesizing
enzymes that they actually need
and that they can't
get anywhere else
from this process
of fermentation.
It's not just about storage.
It's about increasing
the nutrition.
Also unlike other
livestock, bees
retain the resources
to protect themselves.
And that one's I think
fairly straightforward.
The bee's main means
of protecting itself
are the one that we recognize.
But I also wanted to
include this picture.
This is a bee that has
come back from the field.
And on her hind legs
where normally she
stores pollen, where normally
we see pollen being brought
into the hive, that's
actually plant resin.
That's propolis.
What's going to
become propolis which
is the plant resin
that the bees refine.
They use it to coat
the inside of the hive.
They use it to stiffen the comb.
They use it to glue
the stuff together.
Yeah.
They use it to glue
things together.
They use it to reduce the
size of their entrance,
to fill in cracks.
They use it for everything.
But what's important
is, remember
when we were talking a little
bit about essential oils
and that plants produce
essential oils in order
to keep things from eating them.
Well, when they analyzed
the honeybee genome
a couple of years ago, what
they found that was surprising,
the most surprising
thing that we found,
was that there was
almost no immune system.
For a social insect that
lives in this tight colony
with 50,000 or 100,000
individuals in close quarters
and all rubbing
against each other
and going out in the field
and picking up who knows what
and coming back, that they
really didn't have much
in the way of an immune system
the way we understand it.
But what the bees do is they
have this social immunity.
And what they do is they
collect these plant resins which
have substances in them
that protect the plant.
And they're really appropriating
the defense mechanism
of the plant and using it in
their hive for themselves.
Which is really
kind of brilliant.
And of course, if you've
studied the history of medicine
or know anything about
natural medicine,
propolis is one of the oldest
human medicines as well.
Well, I won't go
into detail of that.
But you can, of
course, google it
or Ask Jeeves or whatever
you do around here.
But it's very good
stuff and very powerful.
And as one genius
researcher remarked, well,
if it's good for the humans,
if humans use it and have
medical benefits, maybe
the bees are using it
for a specific reason.
Well, that's why we're using it.
The other thing is that
unlike livestock, bees
are adaptable without
domestication.
We don't have to
domesticate wildebeest
into something that will live
in a barn and get milked.
Bees, they move into
cavities on their own.
This is actually a
ceiling in West Roxbury.
This is a colony that
we removed there.
And this is a telephone pedestal
in Florida, south Florida.
Anywhere where there's a
cavity the bees will move in.
So it doesn't really
take much to convince
them to move into a box.
They're pretty happy to do that.
The other thing that
is kind of worth noting
is that bees are fascinating.
Obviously we're all
here, so there's
some interest in
bees in all of us,
or we wouldn't be in this room.
But when I say bees
are fascinating they
capture our imagination.
And when you look
in a hive, when
you look at
something like this--
this is actually a piece
of comb that was in a wall
that we were
removing in Florida--
but if you ever
looked in a beehive,
or seen pictures of a beehive,
or seen an observation hive,
you have these parallel combs.
And the bees are living on
the comb and between the comb.
And when you observe the
hive, you open it up.
And the bees don't
totally freak out
because you're taking
their home apart
because whoever took their
home apart before we showed up
there, they got 50 million
years of not having anybody
open up their hive gently.
Just a bear ripping
it apart is one thing.
But somebody gently smoking
them and taking the hive
apart, what we're
able to see, it's
almost like reading a book.
That each comb is like
a page of this book.
And as you move
through the combs,
you can see all of these
different processes
that we recognize as
happening in all life.
We see how they assimilate
and digest food,
how they rear their
young, how they reproduce.
We can see them out in the field
doing their thing, collecting
the carbohydrates from the
flowers and the propolis
and the pollen.
We can see all this stuff.
We can see their
stress response.
But as we've got the
hive open for a long time
we can hear them start
to get a little bit
agitated and annoyed.
And so it's very much
like reading a book.
And it's very much like reading
a children's book where you're
looking at an organism, and
each cell in the organism
is kind of animated into
a little character that
has a little antennae and
little wings that goes around
and does their part
of the process.
They go out and they bring
a little bit of nectar back
and they hand it off to
another bee, and that bee
takes that nectar and goes
and puts it into a cell.
And then another bee comes
along and refines that nectar
into honey.
And then another bee comes
along and takes some of that
and eats it so they can
go and generate heat
somewhere else in the colony.
We can actually
observe all this stuff,
where observing it in an
organism they way we're
used to really almost
requires computer animation.
On an even larger
scale-- remember,
plants don't have legs and
they have a hard time moving.
Bees kind of facilitate the
mating dance between plants.
They move the pollen from
one flower to another.
Not for all plants,
but for many plants.
And they're kind
of acting as kind
of a third party in the
mating of all these plants.
And this system of
flowers that require
pollinators, bees being one
of the major pollinators,
this is a very old system.
Not quite as old as the
microbial foundation of life,
but it's kind of the next
step up of life as we know it,
this is the foundation.
The plants produce the sugar
from the sun and sugar,
that sugar that's
produced by the plants,
by the chlorophyll,
that's really
the currency that
life trades on.
That sugar gets traded all
up and down the food chain.
And of course, anybody that's
spent time watching bees
knows that they're
kind of quirky
and they're kind
of fun to watch.
And they capture
our imagination,
and they make an
interesting lens
to look at the natural world.
Because they do things so
differently than we do,
but they're social like we are.
And they do things
so differently
than other kinds of insects
or mice or other animals
that we have.
Yet even though mice are a
lot more like us in many ways,
a lot of social
behavior stuff in humans
is actually modeled in bees.
So a few things about beekeeping
in Massachusetts today
is that land use has
changed quite a bit.
Massachusetts used to be a
major center for beekeeping.
The first Italian queens
to be imported into the US
were imported into
Massachusetts into Colrain
which is in the Western
part of the state.
But what's happened, of
course, is development.
And we know all
about development.
And that's gotten
rid of a lot of land.
But-- and I usually
turn to tree hugging
here, not in the
traditional sense.
The other thing
that's happened is
places that used to
be open fields, that
used to have a
lot of wildflowers
and a lot of nature-- well,
when I was a kid growing up
in this area, they
used to burn them
every few years
to keep them open.
And they stopped doing
that for the most part.
And what happens is, of
course, trees grow up.
And once there are trees, nobody
wants to cut the trees down.
There's a huge resistance
to cutting a tree.
The idea that you're
going to cut a tree down
makes you not an
environmentalist
for some reason.
If, though, you want a
different environment,
the environment that
was there before.
And that's a big problem.
Because areas that used to
be able to support bees,
because of the green
influence, trees
have been allowed to
grow up, and now they're
not so good for bees anymore.
And we don't really
have a way to handle it.
The other issue is,
well, the land use
and the tree hugging
has been happening.
We've have a few
invasive plants that
have turned into excellent
honey producers, Purple
loosestrife and
Japanese knotweed.
What two invasive
plants does the state
spend money trying to eradicate?
Purple loosestrife
and Japanese knotweed.
I'm not advocating that we
let these things grow wild.
I'm just saying that from
a beekeeper's perspective,
these two things
have been happening.
And this has kind
of been our savior.
And now it's a problem.
And it may just be that
we don't have the budget
to fight this stuff anymore,
and it will take care of itself.
And I don't really have a good
solution for this problem,
but it's one worth pointing out.
And recently, we've
been thinking about,
are there unexploited
resources in the state?
And one thought that
has come to mind
is the power line right of ways.
They do use herbicides
on them periodically,
I think every three years.
But kind of trying
to put together
a little plan of
some way to utilize,
because that's excellent
honey producing land.
So all young plants, things
like sumac and wildflowers,
everything's low.
There's plenty of sunlight
because it's kept clear.
This is really something.
And we'd have to work out a way
that we could move the bees out
of the areas that are going to
have the herbicide treatments,
and there's a lot
of infrastructure
that would have to go into this.
But this is one of
the plans that we're
trying to look into as a way
to increase our beekeeping
operation here in Massachusetts.
So a few things that you don't
know about beekeeping but you
should.
Treatments are universal
and feeding is universal.
Almost to a tee.
Almost every beekeeper,
whether they're
a hobbyist or a commercial
beekeeper feeds and treats.
The selection criteria
for breeding stock
is skewed towards the production
of almond and packaged bee
production.
And this is what I was
just talking about,
that there are
bees that are being
bred for the quality of if you
feed them, they make more bees.
That's different than bees that
can take care of themselves
and can regulate their
populations to the environment.
We had about an 80% die off
of bees in Massachusetts
last winter according to
our state bee inspector.
That's significant.
We've got a lot of beekeepers
in the state, but most of them
are hobby beekeepers
with one or two hives.
We did a little bit
better than 80%.
Not a whole lot better.
I think probably about 60%
die off with our own colonies
last winter.
But our bees were
never artificially fed
and they were never medicated.
So I feel like we're a little
bit ahead of the eight ball
there because the bulk of
those bees are medicated.
And if they're being medicated
and they're being fed
and there's still
an 80% die off,
there's something wrong
with that procedure.
And if you're buying honey
from somebody who's a beekeeper
and they never run out
of honey, then you've
got to suspect that they might
be buying in honey sometimes.
And people generally
aren't open about that.
Our model's a little
bit different.
And in fact when
we're done, we've
got some honey for you
all to taste as well.
Now there's a very
strong movement out there
that wants to ban neonicotinoid
insecticides as a way
to save the bees.
This is something that's
swept through Europe
and through the US.
As far as I can tell it's mostly
through very anti-corporate
green groups that
are promoting this.
And they do a very
disingenuous thing.
At least as this
point, we don't have
a cause for CCD, Colony
Collapse Disorder.
We don't have something
that we can say,
this is what causes it.
Nobody has been able to
replicate it in the field
and say, I did this and the bees
died in consistent with manners
they do to colony
collapse disorder.
This is what causes it.
And I'll get into that later.
But what's happened
is that there's
been a move to kind of muddy
the waters a little bit.
And so what happens
is neonicotinoids,
this class of
insecticides, there
have definitely been
overt pesticide poisonings
that have killed a lot
of bees from them, mostly
through the dust they
produce when they plant them.
This is hopefully something
that's being worked on
and something that's going
to get better over time.
If we have a problem
we like to work on it
and we like to solve it.
But the problem is
that in those cases
it's definitely not CCD because
it's overt pesticide poisoning.
We know what the cause is.
They were exposed to a
pesticide and they died.
So what happens is-- and I like
to kind of squish these two
groups together and say, OK.
We have these bees that died
from colony collapse disorder
that we don't what caused it.
But we think it's from
neonicotinoids even though we
can't find the neonicotinoids
in the dying or dead colonies.
Then we've got these bees
that died from overt pesticide
poisoning.
And since we think that that
overt pesticide poisoning is
CCD we're going to
mush them all together
and say that both
groups together all died
from pesticides and
they all died from CCD.
Therefore, CCD is
pesticide poisoning.
This is the logic,
and it isn't true.
And it doesn't do any favors.
We're really a point where
when we talk about CCD,
we're talking about things
that are unexplained.
We're not talking about
overt pesticide poisoning.
The Penn State work that I
was talking about earlier that
looked at the
pesticides in the hive,
when they found those extremely
high levels of the beekeeper
applied pesticides in the
hive, what they were looking
for was the neonicotinoids.
They assumed they were
going to find them.
This was in 2008.
Colony collapse disorder
was big in the news.
It was a new thing.
And the theory that
these pesticides
that were becoming
more and more prevalent
and that were very
toxic to the bees
and that the bees are exposed
to caused this die off
was what everybody
expected to find.
But the studies
haven't backed it up.
And that's been
problematic for those
that have wanted to
stick by that story.
Obviously by this
point, cell phones.
You know, we heard that cell
phones were killing the bees
and cell phone towers
were disorienting them.
That was a German study
on not cell phones
but wireless phones.
And it was mistranslated
and then made all the media
here in this country that cell
phones were killing the bees.
It just simply isn't true.
Did anybody here see this
story about a month or a month
and a half ago?
I think it was in Oregon.
It was all these bumblebees
died in a Target parking lot.
I think they had 17 Linden
trees in this parking lot.
And they were
sprayed with one of
these neonicotinoid
insecticides.
And they had 25,000
bumblebees die.
And they were calling
it a disaster.
Well I'd like to just
offer a little bit
different perspective on that.
You've got a Target parking lot.
You planted 17 trees
to attract pollinators
and you've got 25,000
bumblebees that showed up.
We're told that all these native
pollinators are in decline
and they don't
exist in the wild.
But you've got this parking lot.
Not only were there
25,000 bumblebees
there, but they had
put nets over the trees
because they estimated there
were another 25,000 that
were in danger of
picking up the pesticide.
So you've got one
Target parking lot
with 17 trees attracting
50,000 bumblebees?
I don't think things are quite
as grim as we're told they are.
The other example
on that same line
is we have bees at the
Intercontinental Hotel, which
is right along the Greenway.
And we do a farmer's
market on the Greenway.
And I'm amazed.
It wasn't that along ago that
the Greenway wasn't so green.
Big green steel structure,
but not green in that sense.
And I go around there and I
take pictures of our honeybees
in the flowers on the Greenway
because I like to show those
to the people at
the Intercontinental
and show them what
their bees are doing.
Well what's been amazing is the
number of native pollinators
that have shown up there.
Now, I know why the
honeybees are there.
I've got bees on the roof
a quarter a mile away.
But really, if you
build it they will come.
All they had to do was build
this park, plant flowers
in the middle of the
city-- even though it's
in the middle of the city--
and all these bumblebees
and wasps and all these
tiny native pollinators,
all these pollinators
just showed up.
So again, I don't think things
are quite as grim as they
may appear if one
reads the media.
Fungicides aren't
supposed to hurt bees.
And in fact,
fungicides are allowed
to be used on a lot of crops on
the open bloom, the bloom that
is designed for
the bee to visit.
So that the bees
are actually being
asked to be exposed
to these fungicides
and bring them back to the hive.
I think one report was
that hives coming off
the cranberries in
southern Massachusetts
had 7,000 parts per
billion of a fungicide
in the bees when they came off.
But there's more
and more studies
that are showing even though
the fungicides don't just
kill the bees outright
like a pesticide,
like an insecticide does,
it affects their ability
to raise queens.
It affects their
reproductive ability.
It affects a lot of stuff.
LAURIE HERBOLDSHEIMER:
Their food supply.
DEAN STIGLITZ: It
affects the food supply.
Remember the fermented pollen?
Well, if you need fungi
to do the fermentation
and you've got
fungicides in there
it's kind of like
trying to brew beer
and putting a yeast
killer in the vat.
It doesn't really work.
Insecticides other
than neonicotinoids.
And I talk about
this because how many
here have gotten a petition on
their email that says, oh, we
need to ban these
neonicotinoid pesticides.
Sign this petition.
Well, you go ahead and
you sign that petition.
And I know we're all very
well meaning when we do that.
But do you think that
means that the farmers that
are being banned from using the
pesticide that they want to use
are going to not
use any pesticide?
The reason that we moved
to these neonicotinoids
is they don't require the kind
of aerial broadcasting of crop
dusters that we kind of
are used to historically.
And believe me, there
are a lot of beehives
that died from those
kinds of pesticides.
The idea that you're going to
ban one class of pesticides,
you've got to look
and see what is going
to be used in its
place, and is it
going to be any
better for the bees?
And I think the answer is no.
The treatments,
obviously I've talked
a lot about why I think
the treatments are bad
and why I think the
treatments are a problem,
the feeds are a problem.
Another real issue
is the science.
And although Laurie and I
are not trained scientists,
we're not stupid and
we understand English.
And I have a mind, right?
I can read scientific studies.
And I can understand them
and I can find the flaw.
And there's always a flaw.
Especially when you're dealing
with biological systems.
It's not quite like growing
a crystal or something
like that in a
laboratory environment.
But we've really
gotten the shaft
from the scientists
with the bees.
And a couple that I'd
like to just point out.
Jeff Pettis who is the top
bee researcher with the USDA.
He's our national bee scientist.
He's the guy.
He did a study that showed
that undetectable levels
of neonicotinoid pesticides
make the bees more
susceptible to a
disease, to nosema,
the disease we were
talking about earlier.
AUDIENCE: If they were
undetectable, how do they know?
DEAN STIGLITZ: Well, because
they know if they put it in,
and they know it was diluted.
But here's the problem.
What they did essentially
is they took a hive of bees.
They had controls and
experimental colonies.
But they take a hive of bees.
And for the
experimental colonies,
they'd actually give
them this tiny dose
of neonicotinoid insecticide.
Then after a week or
some period of time
they collected bees from that
hive and put them in a cage.
And they fed those bees
for 30 days in the cage.
And what they did is for some
of them they exposed them
to nosema and some
of them they didn't.
OK?
And the idea was to see if the
bees from the hives that had
this very tiny dose of an
insecticide had more nosema
than the bees that didn't.
Now before this
study was published,
Jeff Pettis was interviewed
in a European film talking
about this.
And this is before the
study was released.
He wouldn't discuss it with
anybody in this country.
Well, when the study
was finally released
and I got a chance to
read it, what I found--
and it's not very hard to find.
It's very straightforward
if you read the procedure.
In that time period where the
bees were caged and exposed
to the nosema--
there were 30 days,
I believe it was, before
they tested the end result--
any bees that died in that
30 days were discarded
and they were never tested
to see if they had nosema.
They had one whole control
set that all died in the cage
and they never tested them.
Now if those bees had
nosema, whether or not
that's what killed
them, it would
have made the results of this
study exactly the opposite.
They just threw away the
data that didn't fit neatly
or that they were afraid
wouldn't fit neatly
into what they were looking at.
You can't do science that way.
It doesn't help anything.
In addition we've got
some other studies.
Tom Seeley is an excellent
researcher at Cornell
and has done some
incredible work
on swarming, the definitive
work on swarming behavior.
He did a study regarding
our practices that we do.
And he claimed that all of his
colonies-- this is controlled
and experimentals-- never
raised a single drone,
never raised a single male
bee throughout the entire
experimental period,
throughout the entire year.
Just simply isn't believable
to anybody that's kept bees.
If you have bees that
aren't raising drones,
there's something
weird going on.
Drones are from
unfertilized eggs.
Even if the queen wasn't
mating, she'd be raising drones.
Even if the sperm wasn't
viable she'd be raising drones.
This was a way to just make
the data a little bit easier
to digest.
And then in another
case, Doctor [? Lu ?]--
this is a study that came out
of the Harvard School of Public
Health that's had a lot of press
nationally, internationally,
and here in the Boston area.
If you look at what was
reported in their study
for the management
of the bees, they
started out the year
in March with hives
that were full of bees
and full of honey.
They fed them every week.
They never took any honey out.
They never gave them more room.
The bees never swarmed.
They were full come fall.
And then within a
month of them having
14 frames of honey,
which is more
than the bees need to
go through the winter,
within a month of that, they
were feeding them again.
None of this makes any sense.
That in March if you
have a full hive of bees,
they're going to swarm.
That colony's
going to reproduce.
If you would see this with
one hive or something,
that's one thing.
But if your entire
experiment are
these bees that were so strong
that they should have swarmed
and they should
have produced honey,
and they should have
needed more room
and none of those
things happened,
it just isn't believable.
And it makes it difficult to
accept anything that they say.
The other one that really gets
me is we get a lot of studies
with bees that only are
looking at one or two hives
or five hives or something.
I'm not a math guy.
But they use statistics
to try to say,
OK, we only had five hives.
But we can apply all
this math and determine
how representative those
five hives are of some whole
that we haven't
measured and we don't
know what the
characteristics are.
I simply don't believe it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what
would you count it
if they had to observe
every hive in the world?
DEAN STIGLITZ: No.
But the problem is
with bees, no matter
how experienced a
beekeeper you are,
if you start two hives next
to each other with as close
to the same lineages as
possible, the same equipment,
to laboratory standards
exactly the same as possible
and manage them exactly the
same throughout the season,
they are not going to look the
same at the end of the season.
So you have a problem
that you haven't
correlated your controls.
And in fact in a
later slide I'll
point out that one of the things
that I think needs to happen
is I think that there need to
be multiple control groups that
get done.
Because multiple control
groups will show you
very quickly if your
statistics are dishonest.
And I'm not saying
that they're always
dishonest-- you're
probably the guy that
does the statistics
here at Google--
but when you're looking at
three hives or five hives
and you try to make this
broad, sweeping thing
and you have all this
math and then you say, OK.
Well, we only have
five hives, but we
can extrapolate what 1,000 hives
looks like, three hives isn't
enough to do that, no matter
how good your math is.
And the problem with all of
this, with the researchers,
there's no good
solution in sight.
You're the researcher.
You made a mistake.
Let's say you made a mistake.
Let's say you know
you made a mistake
or you did something sloppy.
Can you admit it?
No.
Who's going to fund your
next study if you say,
oh, that study that I just spent
three years on that somebody
else paid for, I screwed up
and the data isn't relevant.
But I have this other study
that I really want to do
and I need money for it.
It makes it difficult.
And of course, there's all
kinds of reputations at stake
as well.
So what is the inevitable
outcome of mainstream practice?
Honey that isn't pure because
the feeding is so ubiquitous.
So when I say honey
that isn't pure,
I talk about sugar that
gets into the honey, feed
that gets into the honey.
That's something different than
somebody purposefully mixing
a cheaper sugar in with the
honey, which also happens.
And these beekeeper
applied treatments
can get into the honey as well.
And that can be more of a
problem or less of a problem,
depending on the beekeeper
and the procedures used.
Really what we're
going to end up
is bees that actually
require treatments.
So I talked about if
we treat the bees,
we can't select for bees that
don't require the treatments.
And any kind of
resistance mechanism
has a metabolic
cost to the colony.
So if we remove those
kinds of challenges
we're selecting against
those kinds of strategies
because that metabolic cost
doesn't get them anything.
But really, and this
is kind of interesting
is that there are specific
treatments that literally
become the treatment treadmill.
That you use this
treatment and you
have to use more treatments.
Antibiotics.
I'm talking about for
American [INAUDIBLE]
is a very specific disease.
It is a bacterial infection
that produces spores.
And the spores can live
for 40 years in the hive.
So what happens is
beekeepers use antibiotics
in the hive to kill
the live organism.
And once you start
that cycle and you've
got this healthy population
of spores in the hive,
well those spores are
constantly germinating.
And if you're not constantly
using the antibiotics then
you constantly have
this infection blooming,
and that's a problem.
Fumidil, which is
that stuff for nosema
that I was talking about, what
the new studies have shown
is that yes, using
Fumidil actually
does reduce the nosema
infection in an individual bee.
But when you have
low doses of Fumidil
in the hive like after
it's dissipated sometime
after the treatment,
you know what it does?
It actually
stimulates the nosema
that's left to
produce more spores.
So it's actually a stimulant to
reproducing this thing that you
use the treatment for
in the first place.
So as the concentration dips
down, you've got more spores.
The infection shows up again.
You use the Fumidil
again and it never ends.
We end up with
resistant diseases
and stronger parasites.
And we end up with bees
that require feeding.
One of the other kind of
activist things that comes up
is there's this company
called Beeologics
that has tried to produce
a vaccine for a virus
in bees using this RNAi
technology, which there's
a pretty good Wikipedia article
on RNAi if you're interested.
But how the narrative has
been from the activists that
want you to rally
against Monsanto
is that, oh, there was
this small company that
was looking out for the health
of the bees called Beeologics.
And they were bought out
by the evil Monsanto.
If you do a little
bit of homework
this company was
started by people
who do start ups
and sell companies.
Familiar with the model?
It was started by
a guy who developed
this technology, this RNAi
technology which is useful.
I mean, it's a whole new
technology for agriculture,
for medicine.
Not clear what the
downside is yet.
But basically what was happening
is that he had this technology.
And actually, insects
are an easy way
to demonstrate this
technology because they
can ingest the substance
and incorporate it.
And at the time that they
were coming out with this 2008
colony collapse
disorder was big.
And there was a virus
that was being implicated
called Israeli Acute
Paralysis Virus.
And so they developed a vaccine
against this virus-- which
probably is somewhat
effective-- and claimed
that they could solve CCD.
But we've since learned that
CCD is not really correlated
with Israeli Acute
Paralysis Virus.
But what I just wanted
to get across to you
is that these are part
of the same animal.
This isn't something
nice that was
co-opted by the
big, bad Monsanto.
And what's going
to happen, what I
think is going to happen
if they end up using this,
is that every year
they'll go to the almonds
where three quarters
of the bees congregate,
where you can get
samples very easily.
And they'll sample and
find all the diseases
that are in the populations
of bees that year.
Much like we do with the flu,
kind of like the flu vaccine.
And then they'll have a
product that beekeepers
can buy that have the up to
date stuff with the up to date
vaccines.
And the problem with that is
how do you compete with that?
If you really have bees that are
resistant to every disease that
comes up for bees and every
parasite that comes up
for bees, we're definitely
going to lose our wild bees
because how can you
compete with that?
It's just easy to keep
bees at that point.
What happens to native
pollinators that
have to compete with bees that
don't have to face challenges
and don't have to expend
energy on resistance
to these challenges?
And what happens to the
gene pool of bees over time
if we're not selecting bees
that actually have an ability
to adapt to challenges?
Well, we know what happens.
I'm almost done here.
So a little sampling
check on CCD.
There are increased losses.
There are many reasons for these
losses including pesticides,
including fungicides, including
disease, including mites.
Unlike what you may have heard,
there is capacity for more bees
than we have.
Commercial beekeepers
can produce more bees
if they need them.
We're not at any kind of tipping
point where we're out of bees.
The number of
colonies is largely
a product of market forces.
At this point the
almond pollination
is the thing that runs
the beekeeping industry.
And at $200 a hive
for three weeks
rental a beekeeper is very
motivated to produce more bees
to bring to the almonds if
the market's there for them.
And whereas some years
we do have a little bit
of trouble getting all
the almonds pollinated,
nobody's starving
because we don't
get all the almonds pollinated.
This isn't the kind of crop that
people are eating to survive.
And the other thing that
you have to understand
is that they're planting
almond trees faster
than they have water
to water them with.
So some years the almond
growers are actually
renting beehives
for almond trees
that are never going
to produce almonds
because they don't have water.
Well, why do they do that?
Because they have
crop insurance.
In order to collect
on the crop insurance,
they have to do
everything that they're
supposed to do in order to try
to secure the crop including
renting the bees,
even if they know
that they don't have any
water to produce the almonds.
There are certainly some
businesses that are in trouble.
This is what happens in
industries, the computer
industry, the
information industry.
We see companies fall by
the wayside all the time.
There's nothing
unhealthy about that.
But agriculture, we're
dealing with nature.
And agriculture is always trying
to produce more with less.
Not much different than a
lot of kinds of businesses.
But you can't cure the horse.
You know the story about the
very frugal gentleman that
bought a horse, and they guy
he bought it from said, well,
give him one pail of
oats every day for feed.
Well, this frugal
gentleman didn't really
like the idea of feeding
all these oats to the horse.
So the first day he gave
him the full bucket of oats.
And the second day, he gave
him a half a bucket of oats.
Third day, he gave him a
quarter of a bucket of oats.
And every day he cut it in half,
and the horse was doing fine.
And then one day he saw the
guy who sold him the horse.
And he told him his plan.
And they guy said, well, you
let me know how that works out.
So he ran into the guy
who sold him the horse.
And they guy said, hey,
how's that horse doing?
He said, ah.
He said, you know, he died.
He said, I don't
know what happened.
I had him down to one
grain of oats a day,
and I was going to give him
a half a grain the next day.
I almost had him cured.
You can't cure the horse.
And at some point when you're
dealing with agriculture,
you're dealing with nature or
you're dealing with people.
You can't get more with less.
And at some point
you hit the wall.
And that really
has been what has
happened with the
beekeeping industry.
Tangled up with
some other things
with pesticides and
other agriculture
issues that are going on.
So what can you all
do to help the bees?
You can support sustainable
models of beekeeping.
And I would submit that
there's no sustainable
model of beekeeping
that includes
artificial feeds
and medications.
No matter how you want
to do your accounting,
there's nothing
sustainable about producing
cane sugar in South America,
refining it, shipping it up
to New England to feed your
bees so that you can extract
some honey out of the
hive that they produced.
Even if you can make that
work on paper money wise,
there's nothing
sustainable about that.
That's Kirk Webster.
If anybody has read the
new Bill McKibben book,
"Oil and Honey,"
half the book is
about Bill McKibben and the
other half is about Kirk.
He's one of the beekeepers
who's honey we sell.
Be a critical
thinker and don't buy
into all the mass marketed hype.
And I mean that especially with
the email stuff that you read.
I wish it were so simple
that you could just
click on a petition
and make things better.
But it isn't.
And things don't get better
unless you put yourself out.
Clicking on a petition,
even if it's a good petition
doesn't really do any good.
Because the person
that's reading it
knows that all you had
to do was click on it.
Recognize that beekeeping
and agricultural practices
vary widely.
And different
practices and ideals
have different roles
our overall system.
And I say that
because I don't want
to vilify the
migratory beekeepers.
They're doing an important job.
They are feeding the
masses of the country.
We have this monocrop system.
When we talk about monocrops
we're talking about an area
where there's only
one thing growing.
When there's only
one thing growing
it only blooms for two
weeks during the year
where it needs
insect pollinators.
For the other 50
weeks of the year
there's nothing for
pollinators to eat.
There's nothing to sustain them.
And that's why we have to
be moving these bees around
because they have
two weeks here,
two weeks here, two weeks here.
That's how we grow food
in this country for better
or for worse.
For better if you like feeding
a whole lot of people cheaply.
And for worse if
you like to think
about our environment
and the long term
and where we're
headed and what that
might look like in the future.
Understand the true cost and
true meaning of sustainability.
Again, the honey that we
sell is actually a surplus.
Whether they're from our bees
or from one of our suppliers,
this is not honey from bees
that are being fed back sugar
to make up for
what was harvested.
The art of beekeeping is having
the bees harvest all that stuff
from the land and
providing for themselves
and providing for
you at the same time.
That's when you're doing it.
And there's a cost to that.
It means that you can't
produce as much honey
as if you fed 100
pounds of sugar
and harvested another 100
pounds of honey from that hive.
Support important research that
isn't supported by industry.
Remember that industry,
that 99% of the bees
is 1% of the beekeepers.
And their interest is largely
in that migratory pollination
world, not in the wild bees
that I was talking about.
So that's really what I have
to share with you today.
We have a lot of projects
that we're working on.
We have some research
projects that we're
hoping to collaborate with some
major labs in this coming year.
And we have bees
all around Boston.
We have bees at the
Intercontinental,
at the Lenox Hotel and at
the Fenway Victory Garden.
As you all know by now we wrote
"The Complete Idiots Guide
to Beekeeping."
And we have some honey
for you to taste.
And what we've got
today for honey--
we do different kinds of
tastings different times--
we have three different
kinds of honey.
All from different places,
all from different flowers,
all from different beekeepers,
all from different seasons.
But they all look
almost exactly the same.
And they taste totally
different and they
have totally different textures.
Because it really is
all about the flowers
and not about the bees.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Yes, I have a comment
and a question.
I don't know how
coincidental it was,
but yesterday
there was a program
on NPR about [INAUDIBLE].
And also with the
kinds of [INAUDIBLE].
The reason we all must
harvest the [INAUDIBLE]
is due to the fact that--
well, [INAUDIBLE] Fumidil
could be due to the
beekeepers trying
to keep their number of colonies
up to sustainable levels.
DEAN STIGLITZ: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So I listen
to your [INAUDIBLE].
DEAN STIGLITZ: Well, no.
I mean, sustainable for what?
Sustainable for the pollination
that has to happen, absolutely.
That's the gig.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So that was very interesting
and coincidental.
The second question was back
in 2000 I stumbled upon a book,
and it was before
the CCD [INAUDIBLE]
written in 1923 that basically
predicted colony collapse
disorder.
And it was talking about exact
words what was going to happen.
And I actually
never read the book.
[INAUDIBLE]
DEAN STIGLITZ: Was
it the Steiner book?
Yes.
OK, so he's talking about a
Rudolf Steiner book in 1923
that actually described
colony collapse disorder.
Well, I can one up you on that.
We should have brought
that big poster.
But if you email me
later I'll send you
this document
because it's amazing.
It is a document from the
Secretary of Agriculture,
I think in 1879.
Was that it?
LAURIE HERBOLDSHEIMER: 1870.
DEAN STIGLITZ: 1860
something, 1870 something.
And it describes colony
collapse disorder to a T.
These kinds of boom and bust
cycles are common in insects.
We even see it in the
Bible with locusts.
That's how insects kind of live.
So I can one up Steiner
and show you actually
the Secretary of Agriculture
describing-- not predicting it,
but it happening.
And so I don't find
it that surprising
because it is kind of what
happens when things break down.
Steiner was an interesting guy.
So some of the information's
a little bit wishy washy.
But he certainly
wasn't the only one
to consider that industry and
nature are oftentimes at odds,
and that one's going to beat
down the other eventually.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So to repeat your
answer to the question.
The question was whether
you were aware of it
and whether you agreed with it.
DEAN STIGLITZ: Yeah.
I don't disagree with it.
I agree that where
humans and human nature,
we're not at a place
in our human nature
where we can give
nature it's due.
And that's always
going to cause problems
and disaster and conflict.
I don't know that it takes real
precedence to predict disaster.
Disaster's always
around the corner.
Any other questions or comments?
OK, well if you'd like to come
up we'll do some honey tasting.
And if you'd like
to have your book
signed we can do that as well.
And I appreciate you all coming.
And thank you, Jonathan,
for bringing us in.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
[APPLAUSE]